estoy visitando una ciudad con mi
familia y nos regalaron este mapa para
saber dónde estamos y cómo llegar a
donde queramos observa qué elementos
tiene en este caso los cuadros azules
indican construcciones y cada uno de
ellos es una cuadra el verde es un
parque
los números representan sitios de
interés y por último en la esquina
superior derecha hay un símbolo que se
conoce como rosa de los vientos' la cual
nos indica los puntos cardinales norte
sur este y oeste hemos escuchado que en
la ciudad hay un museo muy interesante
pero no lo veo en el mapa solo tenemos
las siguientes indicaciones que nos
dieron para llegar desde el hotel
caminar tres cuadras hacia el norte 2 al
oeste dos cuadras otra vez al norte y
por último 2 al este me ayuda a
encontrar el museo en el mapa lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es ubicar dónde
está el hotel porque ese será nuestro
punto de partida en el mapa podemos
identificar el hotel con el número 1
perfecto yo ubicamos nuestro hotel ahora
atrás hemos en el mapa las indicaciones
que nos dieron primero tres cuadras
hacia el norte sabes dónde está el norte
en los mapas el norte siempre se
encuentra hacia arriba tal como lo
indica la rosa de los vientos entonces
saliendo de la esquina del hotel
dibujamos una flecha hacia arriba que
abarca tres cuadras después dos cuadras
al oeste el oeste siempre queda a la
izquierda así que dónde termina la
flecha que acabamos de dibujar pondremos
otra que incluya las dos cuadras que nos
dijeron muy bien de nuevo dos cuadras
hacia el norte recuerda que el norte es
hacia arriba ya casi lo ubicamos solo
nos faltan dos cuadras al este en los
mapas el este siempre lo identificaremos
del lado derecho guau logramos encontrar
el museo viste qué fácil es tú puedes
hacer lo mismo siempre que quieras
encontrar un lugar en un mapa
una vez que visitamos el museo
quisiéramos ir a la plaza central cuál
será la mejor ruta para llegar allá
revisemos el mapa y ubicamos primero la
plaza central te acuerdas como muy bien
con los números la plaza es el 2
entonces qué ruta será mejor seguir
podemos irnos dos cuadras al oeste y
luego cuatro cuadras hacia el sur en un
mapa el sur siempre lo ubicará hacia
abajo y luego otra vez cuatro cuadras
hacia el oeste en total caminaremos 10
cuadras otra opción que tenemos es ir
cuatro cuadras al oeste dos cuadras al
sur otras dos al oeste y por último dos
cuadras más al sur daremos más vuelta
pero igual caminaremos diez cuadras pero
hay una diagonal en el mapa que nos
puede servir de atajo para esta ruta
tendremos que ir dos cuadras al oeste
dos hacia el sur dos en diagonal y dos
más hacia el oeste qué te parece en
total serían ocho cuadras mucho mejor
seguro será la ruta que tomaremos la
próxima vez que tengas que ir de un lado
a otro
recuerda considerar varias rutas si tu
destino es un poco más lejos investiga
qué transportes puedes utilizar